well maybe uh more good news with uh
governor cuomo uh resigning
i know you probably heard some rumblings
of that
no rumbling sign no
yeah wait he's not the governor anymore
he's not the governor
he is resigned
no [ __ ]
well because of the
the sexual stuff or the the murder stuff
right it's not it's not the 10 000
people he sent to the death with the
nursing home it's the slapping chicks on
the ass
aspect of uh his government governing
that uh got him out
with that little smoking gun i'm shocked
i'm actually i'm completely shocked
i'm i'm sorry and that i forgot you
didn't know because this whole thing
he resigned and he gave himself two
weeks to resign and that was about a
week or ten days ago so as i sort of
back date this whole thing this must
have been going down while you were
ubering to the airport to leave town
like you just missed this one wow so he
is so okay so he so technically he's
still in that window or no he's gone no
no yes he's gone and i would never want
to be unhelpful in any way
and i think that given the circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
and therefore that's what i'll do
because i work
for you
and doing the right thing
is doing the right thing
for you
because as we say it's not about me
it's about me so he was gone a week or
ten days ago
and and there was you have to add two
more weeks on to that so you just missed
it in other words is what i'm saying and
and the final moment was there a video
was cause i really thought he was gonna
get by it seemed like the ship had
sailed and it was like yeah you killed
all those people you smacked a couple
girls on the ass but we're moving on i'm
shocked yeah i'm completely shocked
they uh they they took his emmy back by
the way
does he have to give the 5 million on
the book advance back to
that uh that he pocketed i don't think
they're going for that but they got the
emmy recall um he
know that the thing that's interesting
about
this and the me too movement and i've
talked to mark gargos about this many
times it's sort of like
the me too movement works this way
if
it was the if it was the law
you'd say well you can have one
murder conviction or you can have 11
jaywalking convictions and it would be
the same you know what i mean so it's an
interesting thing which is another woman
has come out against cuomo and i'm not
here to defend cuomo but another woman
has come out against cuomo what happened
well he put both his hands on my cheeks
and he kissed me on the forehead at a
wedding and it's like
okay and then at a certain point the
news goes now there's 11 women isn't
that enough for him to resign it's like
well not 11 jaywalking tickets that's
not enough to give a guy a murder rap
right so wait is that really what
happened that there was just one more
and finally the damn broke because
nobody cared it was just like ah and by
the way i'm not you know you know my
feelings on this which are the same as
yours about evidence and you know
accusations are just accusations and a
lot of the stuff about you know tapping
someone on the butt or kissing someone
on the head like
it's life like you know but i'm not even
making a judgment call on that but
you're telling me it was just another
one and then it just the scale tipped it
it was essentially there seemed to be
one credible one where he put his
allegedly put his hand up a blouse or
something the rest was a lot of paths on
the bellies and
finger dragging down the spine saying
hey you you know just sort of weird
semi-creepy stuff
ultimately didn't he ask someone to
touch his cannoli or something wasn't
there there was something cannoli
related i think i
it became this sort of
saturation level like people got to a
saturation level with it but essentially
it wasn't sexual abuse it was abuse of
power and if you all know
the one thing the left has to really
come out against is you know a white
male heterosexual male in a position of
power
that is being inappropriate with women
who are well beneath him
in the socioeconomic pecking order so
they couldn't ignore the abuse of power
and it really wasn't i mean again this
is my opinion it was less
sexual abuse because there wasn't any
real defining
right he ripped my blouse off and he
raped me repeatedly it was all
an abuse of authority right it's not
like it's not like he took a cigar and
say he sodomized an intern while on the
phone with trent lott in the white house
like it wouldn't be that kind of thing
yeah not not like that whole jimmy
carter incident you're speaking of yes
not that jimmy wait so dare i ask i
don't even know who the attorney general
or sorry the uh
with lieutenant governor of work is but
i'm gonna guess it's probably somebody
worse so you have to be careful what you
ask for well
i don't want to pop your balloon after
we're sailing so high but uh little
known fact it is
now the governor what no it's gavin
newsom he has dual coastal citizenship
and he's now running both coasts so
sorry dave oh terrible terrible no but i
assume is it someone just like further
left yeah it's a it's a female
lieutenant governor who's uh stepped in
to fill the void
so he's out and again this is the
problem the left never stops talking
about every woman needs to be believed
and you know after they do their hit
piece on kavanaugh and all that kind of
stuff and then when it happens to one of
their own they would be insane
hypocrites to say well you know
kavanaugh's a rapist but cuomo is just
fine
and they pin themselves into a corner
essentially because they never stop
bloviating about every you know every
woman needs to be heard and every woman
needs to be believed and now what are
they going to say there's 11 women don't
listen to them it's exactly what i
always say about you call everybody a
nazi it's not what you're doing to all
of them it's what you're doing to
yourself because you can't suddenly be
like ah
that one i call the nazi that's not the
nazi well it's it's vaccine
mandates and sorry vaccine passports and
ids i mean this is a recent story that
you may have missed but you probably did
the math
you have all these governors of all
these blue states explaining that
showing an id to vote is jim crow 2.0
and all these same governors have now
legislated that you need to show an id
and a vaccine card to enter a bar a gym
a restaurant a federal building a public
building a public space and obviously
in new york city it's pretty
astronomical in terms of the groups that
have not been vaccinated cnn would tell
you it's a bunch of guys driving ram
pickup trucks with american flag
but statistically it's the
african-american community so
basically two-thirds to three-quarters
of black new yorkers are not vaccinated
and you've now told all those people
they can't enter a bar or restaurant
without providing an id but that it
would be jim crow if they had to provide
an id to vote so you've crapped all over
your own point well that's why the lying
about the voter id laws was so dangerous
it was such a dangerous game that they
were playing in georgia and texas and
some of those other states to keep
saying it's racist to show an id because
congratulations here we are now you want
us to all walk around with your your
little vaccine mandate okay your little
card well i'm not showing my id for it
god it's evil that's what i'm talking
about when i talk about just like evil
just spreading throughout the system
these liars they and that's why they
always go crazy right if you're just
lying about everything all the time then
you always have to ratchet up the crazy
i'm shocked about this cuomo thing
alright so that's good that's good if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell